and then the other thing and here's what
you say anybody young tonight is it like
in your 20s or 30s and when you hear
that [__] like
here's what you say like oh yeah it's so
awesome being young in America it's so
great can't afford College if we do go
to college I got crushing student loan
debt can't afford a house we're afraid
to have kids because of climate collapse
there's no good jobs out there we can't
afford health care they're the only jobs
are like oh we have to have three jobs
delivering food and working for Uber if
we do get a good job it's with some
Silicon Valley billionaire [__] with
venture capitalist money creating
[__] or or that Silicon Valley or
those billionaires they creating cool
stuff to end homelessness and stop
climate collapse no it's always some
stupid like cat food home delivery app
cat snack chat app snack